well women have made significant strides
in home ownership but when it comes to
being property investors females need a
little bit better representation kirsten
joyce takes a look at one program that
is trying to bridge that gap
[Music]
and this is a really exciting career
it's a very lucrative career shane
steele is the chief marketing officer
for sunday a company that brings home
seller together with investor sellers
who don't want to deal with repairs or
showings selling their homes as is to
the best offer from a property investor
on average homeowners get back about 12
offers in just a couple of days because
there's so many property investors
looking for
real estate and we want to get more
women participating steel says only 30
percent of property investors across the
united states are women to help bridge
that gap this week sunday launched an
online program that provides resources
tools and inspiration education for
women on how to get started and how to
expand upcoming sessions next week you
can register for to hear from women who
are very successful in this field we're
going to be sharing their stories about
how they got into property investing
like i said what are some of the unique
challenges that women face in property
investing which by the way is very
similar to what we see in other
industries right it's you know lack of
career advancement it's lack of
mentorship there are currently more than
500 property investors participating in
the marketplace across our state the
company says the more property investors
it has participating the better it is
for the homeowner and the more women
that get involved the more diverse and
representative of the community kiersten
joyce live local now